so this movie is directed by one of the
main producers behind movie 43 That
awkward moment stars Zac Efron Michael B
Jordan and miles teller and what this
movie is about is three guys who decide
to make a pact that they are not going
to get into a relationship they're
allowed to be with as many girls as they
want sexually but relationship happens
they lose the bet the funny thing is
there's nothing on the line they don't
actually don't actually bet anything so
what's the point that's really the plot
of this movie and of course they start
to fall for various girls because while
they're doing this bet they decide you
know what let's go out and look for
girls I wonder what will happen when you
look for girls that you want to be with
if you can't tell I wasn't a big fan of
this movie and it's because all the
characters in this movie are idiots it's
one of those movies where characters
continue to do things and you're like
why dude why that was basically my
reaction for the majority of the scenes
in this movie in fact a lot of the
scenes ended with another character
going you're an idiot it actually came
to a point where it was a game I was
playing in my head I was like I wonder
if this scene is gonna end with someone
saying hey you're an idiot you're an
idiot man cuz like every scene ends that
way I'm not even joking Zac Efron
Michael B Jordan and miles teller are
three really likeable actors miles
teller was great last year in the
spectacular now Michael B Jordan was
fantastic in Fruitvale station these are
really talented guys and I don't even
mind Zac Efron I've seen him do good
stuff in the past he's okay in this
movie and these three guys have a good
rapport with one another that's deadly
the best part of this movie these three
guys do seem like friends and they
bounce off each other really well and
that was by far the part of this film
that I thought excelled the most was the
chemistry between the actors some of the
girls are also really good in the movie
and that's not really my issue with the
film the acting was about as good as it
can beat with the screenplay they had to
work with my issue is the screenplay
is filled with romantic cliches to the
point where you can literally tell where
everything is about to happen but I
think the movie feels like it's a little
more clever than it actually is because
of these cliches I mean every single
character in the movie has the big
argument scene where oh the relationship
isn't going so well let's have a big
argument scene and of course all
three of these guys seem to have this
around the exact same period and they
clash of course because you can't have a
movie where characters get into an
argument with a whole bunch of different
relationships unless they all end up in
the exact same place having a big
argument that somehow involves all the
characters because then it wouldn't be a
movie now we've seen that work really
well before in the past with movies like
Crazy Stupid Love the best scene in that
movie in my opinion is when all the
characters mean you're like oh my
goodness you see where everything is
going now and that was great it was
really well written the character seemed
real and it was surprising in this movie
when that moment happens which really is
just trying to copy off a whole bunch of
other romantic comedies where that exact
same moment has happened it doesn't feel
real it just feels forced like okay now
we get the montage of sadness the
montage of sadness is something I've
mentioned before in reviews and it
always happens in romantic comedies or
romance films of any sort a character is
now at a low spot more than likely these
people have had their first argument
ever it's really serious first argument
that of course possibly will break up
the relationship and this movie has that
for everybody I'm sick of these movies
that follow the exact same pattern over
and over again and don't offer anything
new the only thing I can say that's
positive about this movie is the fact
that these guys have good chemistry with
one another of course it takes place in
New York and now I haven't read any
other reviews yet so maybe some other
people have said this but to me this
just felt like Sex in the City for
single guys where you know they're
walking around New York talking about
relationships it's supposed to be funny
but it's not really that funny like to
me that's what Sex in the City was no I
don't want to spoil anything in this
movie but there is a scene this movie
that I won't spoil it because near the
end that involves a large group of
people and applause and I was like
they're clapping it was like the slow
clap
in my opinion that awkward moment is
just a cliched romantic comedy that's
trying to be smarter than it is but it
fits in just right at the end of the
month of January
trust me I'm going to give this film a
d-plus so guys if you have seen the
movie which something tells me you
probably didn't tell me what you thought
of it below as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you liked this
review you can click right here and get
stuck
nice
[Music]